let h be the vertical distance between
the graphs of f and g in region s
find the rate at which h changes with
respect to x when x is equal to 1.8
so
we have region s right over here you
can't see it that well since i drew over
it and what you see in region when we're
in region s the function f is greater
than the function g it's above the
function g
and so we can write h of x
we could write h of x as being equal to
f of x
minus g of x
and what we want to do is we want to
find the rate at which h changes with
respect to x
and so we could write that as h prime of
we could say h prime of x we want the
rate when x is equal to 1.8 so h prime
of 1.8 is what we want to figure out now
we could evaluate f prime of 1.8 and g
prime of 1.8 and to do that we would
take the derivatives of each of these
things and we know how to do that it's
it's within our capabilities but it's
important to realize when you're taking
the ap test that you have a calculator
at your disposal and a calculator can
numerically and
integrate and can numerically
evaluate derivatives and so whenever
they're they actually want us to find
the area or evaluate an integral where
they give the endpoints or evaluate a
derivative at a point well that's a
pretty good sign that you could probably
use your calculator here and what's
extra good about this is we have already
essentially inputted h of x in the
previous steps and really in part a i
had defined this function here and this
function is essentially h of x i have
the out i took the absolute value of it
so it's always positive over either
region but i could delete the absolute
value if we want so let me delete that
absolute value then i have to get rid of
that parenthesis at the end
so let me
delete that and so notice this is h of x
we have our f of x which is 1 plus x
plus e to the x squared minus 2x
and then we from that we subtract g of x
so we have g of x
was a positive x to the fourth but we're
subtracting so negative x to the fourth
let me show you g of x right over here g
of x is right over here and notice we
are subtracting it so the y one as i've
defined it in my calculator and i just
press this y equals button right over
here that is my h of x
and so now i can go back to the other
screen and i can evaluate its derivative
when x is equal to 1.8 i go to math
i
scroll down
we have n derivative right here and so
click enter there and what i'm going to
take the derivative of well the function
y sub 1 that i've already defined my
calculator i can go to variables
y variables it's already selected
functions so i'll just press enter and
i'll select the function y sub 1 that
i've already defined so i'm taking the
derivative of y sub 1 i'm taking the
derivative with respect to x
and i'm going to evaluate that
derivative when x is equal to 1.8
that's simple
and then i click enter and there you
have it it's approximately negative
three point eight one two
so approximately negative three point
eight
one
two
and and we're done and you know one
thing that you might appreciate from
this entire question and even the the
question one is
they they really want to make sure that
you understand that underlying
conceptual ideas behind derivatives and
integrals and if you understand the
conceptual ideas of how do you use them
to solve problems
and you have your calculator at disposal
that these are not too hairy that these
can be done fairly fairly quickly